you might be wondering can I attend the
biggest gaming convention of the year
what trailers should I be looking at for
today and did yet another perk longer
update arrived today well the answers to
those are yes Zelda and you bet it did
here's the latest i'll stop a gorgeous
new trailer for The Legend of Zelda
breath of the wild has arrived it's just
under a month until this one hits
shelves but if you need something to
whet your appetite ahead to the game's
Japanese website you can find a link in
a story on gamespot the trailer shows
off some lovely varied environments
action sequences horse riding and new
shots of the gargantuan guardian
creatures you'll also get a closer look
at some of the people and creatures link
will be encountering in the game both
friend and foe breath of the wild
releases for switch and Wii U on the
third match if you're still playing
pokemon go one good on you and to the
Valentine's Day event has kicked off
today as you'd expect quote adorable
pink Pokemon will show up more
frequently including paragon clefable
and Chancey hatching eggs is also more
likely to net you a clever Smoochum or
eagerly buff there are also various
bonuses up until the event wraps on
februari 15 including twice as much
candy rewarded for catching hatching and
transferring Pokemon and body Pokemon
fueled by the power of love will find
candy in half the usual time on top of
that lower modules will be more
effective than usual lasting for six
hours which is heaps more than their
usual 30 minutes if floor modules laughs
for more than six hours see your health
care professionals finally you can go
III this year I know it's very exciting
and you don't have to sit in the
conference room working the whole time
like gamespot do so the first time ever
III is opening its doors to the public
this year fifteen thousand tickets will
be made available for anyone to buy come
fare per team they are priced at a lofty
250 bucks but that includes access to
the show floor panel discussions and
other events throughout the three-day
conference there is also a 150 dollar le
bear
tickets available if you're quick the
entertainment software association said
the feedback we heard was clear the
people wanted to play the games inside
the convention center in addition
exhibitors inside the convention center
wanted to have access to the fans so
this year we're bringing the two
together adding the decision to open our
doors to 15,000 fans was a strategic
decision a through 2017 takes place
between jun 13 to 15 that is everything
I got for you today do let me know what
you cared about in that comment section
Hebda games but the stories on the
division and persona 5 and I'll catch
you tomorrow